there's a recall announced for dry  shampoos high levels of benzene were  found and yes Benzene can cause cancer  but Health Canada actually said that the  amount of benzene in the products  wouldn't be expected to harm your health  I didn't find the actual Benzene  concentrations in the products published  anywhere but it is similar to other  recalls in the past it's probably a few  parts per million which is a fraction of  a drop of benzene in a can you probably  get more Benzene exposure from breathing  in City air for half a day so this  recall is actually a good sign that the  system is working and Brands and  Regulators are taking action before  anyone is really getting hurt